[Music]
this is Gila
he's a Gila monster the only species of
lizard natured to the United States that
is venomous but don't worry these
laggard lizards aren't exactly known for
their ability to give chase native to
the southwestern United States and
northwestern Mexico the Gila monster is
a hard to spot desert dweller spending
90% of its day underground squat and
heavy set with a large tail and head
they grow to be about 20 inches long and
weigh two pounds their skin is studded
with dorsal scales black in color with
scattered passions of orange and red
hues they camouflage well amongst desert
pebbles and rocks gila monsters prey on
small desert animals and their eggs by
using their acute sense of smell once
located they bite into their prey with
their teeth and don't let go they chew
relentlessly until the venom stored in
their salivary glands can work its way
into their prey or they're quite toxic
their bite is not fatal to adult humans
sadly the number of gila monsters in the
wild are dropping
they've lost their habitat to housing
and agriculture development but since
they spend most of their time
underground we do not know how many are
left this is the Gila monster
[Music]
you